hey this is presh talker
start with the pair of fractions
two over one times two over three
now increase every single number in this
pair by two
this becomes four over three times four
over five
once again increase every single number
in this pair of fractions by two
we get six over five times six over
seven
if you repeat this process infinitely
many times
you'll end up with an infinite product
of fractions which are exactly equal to
pi divided by two
this formula can be more compactly
written in product notation
this is the product of two k divided by
two k minus one times two k over two k
plus 1
where k runs from 1 to infinity
this fantastic formula for pi was
described in 1655.
wallace was studying integrals of the
form
1 minus x to the power of 1 over p
all raised to the power of q
evaluated from 0 to 1.
through extensive calculation wallace
found a pattern this integral was equal
to p factorial times q factorial divided
by p plus q factorial
well he discovered it was true for
positive integers at least
he wasn't able to evaluate this integral
for non-whole numbers
but he wondered
what would happen if p equals q equals
one-half
the integral would simplify to the
square root of one minus x squared
evaluated from zero to one
this integral was familiar
it describes the area of the unit
quarter circle
therefore
it must be equal to pi divided by 4.
wallace was able to take this result for
pi over 4 and combine it with
interpolating his other calculations
to come up with something resembling
what we now say is the wallace product
formula
in fact wallace stumbled across another
interesting result which we know today
if you were to substitute
into this factorial formula p equals q
equals one-half
and equate it to pi over four
you end up with this rather strange
result
that one half factorial squared is equal
to pi over four
taking the square root of both sides
means that the factorial of one half is
equal to the square root of pi over two
this is the value we assign to the
factorial one-half today
and it's a rather interesting thing that
you can define the factorial function
over non-whole numbers
i provided a separate video which gives
some intuition about what
factorials are for numbers that are not
whole numbers
you can go ahead and watch that video
for now i'm going to continue on with
this wallace product
the modern proof is related to integrals
that wallace was studying
we'll simplify this with the
substitution that x equals cosine of
theta
we'll change the limits of integration
and substitute in the correct variables
we now remember the identity that one
minus cosine squared of theta is equal
to sine squared of theta
we essentially end up studying the
integral of sine to the power of n
it will be convenient to study this
integral from zero to pi
so let's see what happens when we do
that
we'll define i sub n as the integral
from 0 to pi of sine to the power of n
we're going to integrate this
by doing integration by parts
we'll set u equal to sine to the power
of n minus 1 and dv equal to sine of x
dx
we calculate d u and v accordingly
the integral is then equal to uv
minus v d u
i will substitute in those terms
now let's evaluate this
the first term is sine to the power of n
minus 1 of x times negative cosine of x
we want to evaluate this from zero to pi
now sine of x is equal to zero for both
pi and zero
so sine to the power of n minus one of x
is also going to be equal to zero at
those values so the first term is going
to become zero
the second term has two
factors of cosine of x inside the
integral
rather two terms of cosine of x so we
can combine these cosines of x to get
cosine squared of x multiplied by sine
to the power of n minus 2 of x
we'll then use the formula that cosine
squared of x is equal to 1 minus sine
squared of x
we'll split this integral up into two
different integrals
one integral has sine to the power of n
minus two the other integral has sine to
the power of n
this allows us to write our formula in
terms of i sub n minus 2 and i sub n
now recalling all of this is equal to i
sub n
we can then solve for i sub n
i sub n will be equal to n minus 1
divided by n
times i sub n minus 2.
we've come up with the type of reduction
formula
we can solve for the integral i sub n
in terms
of the lower powered integral
i sub n minus 2
and we have the ratio of i sub n over i
sub n minus 2
equal to n minus 1 over n
this is going to be important we're
going to be looking at the ratio of
these integrals
so i'll copy over this formula
and we're going to split it up into two
different cases
we can rewrite this formula in terms of
just even numbers
i sub 2 n over i sub 2 n minus 2
and we can also consider it just for odd
numbers i sub 2 n plus 1 over i sub 2 n
minus 1.
so for even numbers we'll start out with
i sub zero
sine to the power of zero is equal to
one so we have the integral from zero to
pi of one dx
this is equal to pi
what would happen if we want to evaluate
i sub 2 n
we have this reduction formula in terms
of i sub 2 n minus 2.
now we can apply this formula on i sub 2
n minus 2.
this gets us to i sub 2 n minus 4.
we can repeatedly apply this formula all
the way until we get down to i sub 0
which is equal to pi
so we now can write i sub 2 n in terms
of a product formula
we have pi
times the product of 2 k minus 1 over 2
k
where k runs from 1 to n
we'll do a similar thing for the
odd numbers
we start out with i sub 1 equaling sine
to the power of 1 of x dx
going from 0 to pi
this is equal to 2.
for a general odd number we're going to
use the reduction formula
we can then apply the reduction formula
on i sub 2 n minus 1
to get to i sub 2 n minus 3.
and we can continue this all the way
until we get down to i sub 1 which is
equal to 2.
so now we have i sub 2 n plus 1 in terms
of a product formula we have 2 times the
product of 2 k over 2 k plus 1 where k
runs from 1 to n
so we have one formula for even numbers
and we have another formula for odd
numbers
we're going to consider the ratio of
these integrals
but before we do that we need to
understand what happens as n increases
now between 0 and pi
sine of x is always between 0 and 1.
whenever you multiply a number between 0
and 1 by itself
you end up with a smaller number
so every time we raise the power on sine
we're going to be smaller than or equal
to what we had before so sine to the
power of 2n plus 1 has to be less than
or equal to sine to the power of 2n
which is less than or equal to sine to
the power of 2n minus 1.
this means when we take the integral
from 0 to pi of each of these functions
we have the same inequality going on
i sub 2 n plus 1 is less than or equal
to i sub 2 n which is less than or equal
to i sub 2 n minus 1.
we now divide each term in this
inequality by i sub 2 n plus one
the first term becomes one
the second term becomes i sub two n over
i sub two n plus one
and the final term becomes i sub two n
minus one over i sub two n plus one
we know this is equal to two n plus one
over two n because we've calculated the
ratios of these integrals before
so now what happens if we take the limit
as n goes to infinity
well two n plus one over two n
approaches the value of one
so we have an inequality where the lower
bound is one and the upper bound is one
so we squeeze out the limit of the terms
in between so that we get the limit as n
goes to infinity of i sub 2 n over i sub
2 n plus 1 is equal to 1.
so what is this ratio i sub 2 n over i
sub 2 n plus 1.
we can use our product formulas we know
what i sub 2 n is and then to take
i sub 2 n plus 1 we want to divide by it
so we take the reciprocal of each term
we end up with the product formula that
pi over 2
times the product
of the following fractions equals 1.
we now want to solve for pi over 2 and
we can do that by taking the reciprocal
of each term in this product
we then end up with what we wanted to
prove which is the wallace product
formula pi over 2 is equal to the
product of the two fractions 2k over 2k
minus 1 times k over two k plus one when
k goes from one to infinity
so this is the proof of this miraculous
and fantastic formula for pi
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like the
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description